still haven't decided which version of  Zelda to pick up I'm Tony and this game  spot news update is here to help breath  of the wild is coming to both Nintendo  switch and we you both run at 30 frames  per second and include the same content  however the switch version will render  at 900p on your TV while the wii u  version tops out at 720 of course the  on-screen button prompt will also be a  bit different additionally the switch  version has higher quality sounds  meaning things like your footsteps  running water and wind will just sound  better the wii u disk version also  requires a 3 gigabyte install and the  special and master editions are only  available on switch Legend of Zelda  breath of the wild launches for Wii U  and Nintendo switch on March third the  same day the switch itself releases  which version are you picking up let me  know in the comments or on Twitter at  chain gun Pope and to keep up with all  the latest Zelda news be sure to  subscribe